[Musik]
ja Russlands neue Strategie scheint
darin zu bestehen die Ukraine wirklich
zurück in die Steinzeit zu bomben
gestern haben wir Angriffe auf 11
Kraftwerke im Land gesehen heute
Angriffe auf zwei weitere Kraftwerke und
wir wollen uns noch einmal ansehen wie
Russland das ganze versucht jetzt kurz
vor dem Winter sozusagen die die Ukraine
hier kaputt zu bomben wir haben gestern
diese Bilder gesehen aus Kiew für uns
erreicht haben einmal hier ein Einschlag
und im Zentrum der Stadt und zwar in der
Nähe eines Kraftwerkes wir sehen das
auch auf der rechten Seite dort und
jetzt sehen wir es hier oben und das
können wir einmal ganz kurz anhalten ein
weiterer Marschflugkörper vom Typ
Calibre der hier fliegt der hier über
die Kamera rüber fliegt und wir sehen
jetzt noch mal die typische Flugbahn die
er beschreibt wir versuchen es mal zu
konzentrieren auf den und wir sehen dass
ihr etwa in einer Höhe von 800 Meter
hier fliegt noch mit
Unterschallgeschwindigkeit jetzt steigt
er nach oben kurz vor seinem Ziel und
geht dann mit Nacht zwei also mit
zweifacher Schallgeschwindigkeit wir
sehen uns hier weiter fliegt nach unten
und fliegt auch auf das Kraftwerk zu und
explodiert dann hier das also ganz
typisch für die russischen
marschflowkörper wie sie sich eben
bewegen und weshalb es möglich ist sie
vor dem Einschlag wenn Sie also noch
über Land fliegen das sind ja einige
Minuten wenn sie vom Schwarzen Meer
kommen beispielsweise abzufangen und das
Ganze ist gestern auch passiert und das
hier sind Aufnahmen die wirklich
beeindrucken ukrainische Soldaten
versuchen ihre Familien ihre Städte die
ja da die Orte die angegriffen werden zu
schützen wir hören erstmal
Maschinengewehrfeuer die Ukrainer sehen
dass ein Marschflugkörper kommt zuerst
wird auf ihn geschossen das klappt aber
nicht
hier vorne sehen wir einmal können wir
drauf konzentrieren wie ein Soldat eine
schultergestützte fluchtabwehrwaffe
nutzt und zwar eine ECLA eine eine
sowjetische eine sowjetische
flugabwehrwaffe und wir hören ja einfach
mal wie zuerst jetzt der marsch-körper
rüber fliegt da Ware und wie jetzt der
Soldat hier vorne den Marschflugkörper
tatsächlich hinterher schießt und
versucht ihn zu erwischen und ja wir
hören wie sie und Soldaten fluchen und
kaum zu glauben wir sehen uns hier
hinten der Soldat trifft das heißt
dieser Marsch verkörper wurde
abgeschossen da wurden Leben gerettet
und gerettet von diesen Soldaten die
hier versucht haben ja eben die die
russischen marshmallowkörper auf dem Weg
in die ukrainischen Städte abzufangen
was passiert wenn die Marshall Körper
nicht abgefangen werden sehen wir auf
diesen Aufnahmen gestern aus the Nitro
aus der Stadt niebro in einem östlichen
Zentrum der Ukraine eine dashcam eines
Autos Zeichen hier erst ein erstes
Explosion auf und dann eine zweite
direkt auf der Straße kein militärisches
Tier in der Nähe wieder ging es hier um
wahrscheinlich um Gasleitungen die auf
der Straße geführt haben der der
Autofahrer dreht jetzt und ganz spannend
ist zu sehen wie schnell die Ukraine
versucht haben diesen Schaden dort zu
reparieren wir sehen auf einem Foto
erstmal von gestern von direkt nach dem
Angriff und zwar hier wir sehen eine
riesigen Kater in der Stadt hier ein Bus
der teilweise zerstört wurde da wurden
elf Menschen drin verletzt zwei von
ihnen schwer und wir sehen auch hier
einen kleinen Kiosk im Hintergrund mit
einer Klimaanlage oben drauf und wir
halten ja einfach mal im diesen Kiosk da
im Sinn und sehen was jetzt passiert
nämlich dieses Foto ist von heute wir
haben wir wiederum den Kiosk hier die
kleine Klimaanlage und wir sehen der
Krater ist Weg über Nacht haben die
Ukraine diese Straße wieder repariert so
dass heute eben wieder auf ihr ganz
normaler Verkehr herrschen kann so also
versuchen sie relativ rasch hier die
Schäden die durch diese massiven Schäden
die gestern erzeugt wurden durch die
russischen Angriffe wieder wegzumachen
und wir wollen uns auch ansehen ein
neues Video was uns erreicht hat von
einer ukrainischen Drohne die hier ein
Angriff
und zwar eine sogenannte ram2 Drohne das
ist ein Kamikaze Drohne die die Ukraine
nutzt die auch die Ukraine selbst baut
eine ukrainische Firma baut die und wir
sehen hier unten ein russisches
flugabwehrgeschütz was davon angegriffen
wird wir sehen also hier die Kamikaze
Drohne die fliegt wir sehen da unten
dann das abwehrgeschütz und sehen wie
die Kamikaze Drohnen dort einschlägt und
dieses flugabwehrgeschütz zerstört so
also ist es auch möglich dass man
tatsächlich Kamikaze Drohnen gegen
militärische Ziele einsetzt so wie die
Ukraine es tut und nicht gegen zivile
wie Russland ist tot hier noch mal kurz
zu dieser Drohne dass wir gesagt eine
ukrainische Drohne die bereits seit
einigen Jahren hergestellt wird wir
sehen einen ein Gefechtskopf von drei
Kilogramm hat sie und er kann 30
Kilometer weit fliegen also eine
Kurzstrecken Drohne auf jeden Fall in
jedem Fall so also die Taktik der
Ukrainer während Russland versucht die
Zivilisten anzugreifen setzt und die
Ukraine weiterhin auf Angriffe auf
russische militärinfrastruktur
[Musik]